why these teachers look so bad now but i
had the ugly ones growing up
i can't stand that i had these dragons
these men in black characters
i had these warlocks teach me earth
science
i see some of these teachers [ __ ]
with these kids oh my god talk to
you sign me up thank you i'll go back to
the special ed class i'm talking about
also i love the 16 year old with a
mustache i'm like it was terrible
she used to suck my dick every day after
class i'm like who's
right thank you thank you thank you
you're living buddy to get to the real
world
it's crazy that this [ __ ] goes down like
that crazy crazy how about the one
teacher it was a dime piece got caught
the kids running a tree train on two of
them
i said you didn't
yes she got arrested and then the kids
on the news
we can't believe it we we double
penetrated her i'm like oh
what though what that was me neither you
know the bond those two
created thank you thank you you talked
that [ __ ] just
i'm sitting here writing love albums
kids are running [ __ ] trains you're
writing love novels [ __ ]
billy and timmy over there doing double
anal damn
whoa i didn't know it yeah well again
well
i was thinking
[Applause]
yeah some of these teachers are like
where are them yeah but i try to fight
my teachers these kids are out here
freaking running trains and i hate it
what's crazy is the teachers are coming
on to them yeah
really yeah i had new shoes every day in
high school now one teacher got at me
oh i would i would wear short shorts
shark
dog i had a teacher named miss ro this
is [ __ ] up just hear me
okay it is what it is a teacher named
miss roach and uh
she had shouts out she's so [ __ ] up
her name is miss roach
and she had cancer of her on her face
and it
it it took off her nose and like
one of her eyes the magazine so she
would wear a prosthetic
but when you're in sixth grade at rory
hills middle school which is a rough
school
someday she wouldn't put the prosthetic
on so just be like juicy
like hole in her face ugh and i was next
door
right so they they separated by like
bookshelves dude listen nothing but
listen this
where they were turning the lights were
off they're like movie time
and she was like you know her face was
gone
and so i was next door like watching a
movie and the kids next door watching
the movie mr rose class
and you share hope and she you know she
probably couldn't see out of the eye
tripped over the cord and we just see
her in a wheelchair getting carted off
we're like i didn't oh my god
shout out to rory hill's mike look at
chin's face it just feels cute
get over the you know think about how
big of a distraction is if you're
sixth grade how he just laid her out
like this
dude i'm not laughing at this situation
you're flopping here oh
damn you remember that sam put her in
the casket who put them in the casket
when they fall oh put them in a coffin
right oh yeah people don't believe
i found a picture of me as a uh in a
high school
all right you i'll save it for cats say
forget oh yeah yeah okay
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this is from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son